it's kind of been a weird world that i
fell into
fundraising for charities with live
streaming so what can i do with that
let's do something amazing
my name is anna marie manciette and i
play games for a living i am currently
in memphis i've been teasing this uh for
quite a while i'm going to be live
streaming from the saint jude campus
tomorrow at 5 00 p.m we're trying to
raise 5 000 in four hours for st jude
we're also going to be streaming with
miguel who is a former stu patient and
i'm so excited to see you guys all there
hello hey miguel it's anna marie here hi
everybody how are you i'm good how are
you doing i cannot wait for you to see
the place that i call home
really emotional but really exciting all
right we'll see you soon
see you soon bye bye
it feels wrong to say um because it
feels selfish
um
and i don't know if that's
the right answer
um
but in my family you don't grow old
you die of cancer
and today
is the one year anniversary of losing my
grandfather
i i know for a fact that this is why i'm
here
my name is miguel and i came to saint
jude as a patient but now i stay as an
employee giving back to the hospital
that saved my life
we're going to prep you for tomorrow's
stream
we have
two experts they're going to be teaching
you how to play you guys are experts
not really
so colton mcgill is new at playing
minecraft we're going to be trusting
both of you to lead us here
one of the greatest things when i was a
patient at st jude was to play with my
fellow patients
we were born over the games
and the sense of community
it truly helps
double space yeah so keep holding so
what is the one thing i need to know
um don't die minecraft don't die
minecraft
[Music]
and here we go
hi my name is anna marie i'm here with
the awesome miguel
we are currently fundraising for saint
jude play live i'm just very lucky and
honored and again blessed to be here
with not only with saint jude and also
alienware i just want to do a quick
shout out to carlton cause i mentioned
him earlier on the stream and he just
dropped in the chat he said hey this is
colton i play minecraft yesterday at
target house is it minecraft time it's
minecraft time i'm right here just
running away from this
now we're safe
no oh no you applied to me whoa this
friendship is built on lies thank you
anonymous for the 25
donation sarah donated
135 dollars colton and landon they also
donated 25 insurance i wonder why
minecraft is so great like do you you
understand it now though right we're
almost at the halfway mark um so shout
out and thank you to everybody um who
has donated thus far uh there's a
skeleton in front of you i thought that
was you
wait what
so my dad donated a thousand dollars
hey baby hey dad you hit your number yet
no
we're we're past halfway now we have an
hour left we're at three thousand out of
our five thousand dollar goal you'll hit
it
i know how much this means to you
very proud of what you're doing
thank you dad
so we have less than about 22 minutes
left in the stream i'm pretty sure we
can do this
we have a hundred dollars from varbals a
hundred dollars from zach we have a
hundred dollars from lena a hundred
dollars from anonymous a hundred dollars
from logan
[Music]
we just hit
five thousand
you and play dollars
and the lights are changing colors
[Applause]
[Music]
for me gaming changed my life
what's nice about what i do for
alienware is i just wanted to be
somewhere within this industry that i
could give back
and i'm here
[Music]
you